absolument le ministre de la Défense les
ministère de la Défense Paris
excusez-moi a fait son briefing mensuel
ce matin briefing un peu plus étendu
évidemment ils se sont exprimés à
différents représentants du ministère en
fait sur la situation à Solidar mais
aucune annonce vraiment à faire si ce
n'est ce que de dire que cela n'a pas
vraiment de sens que d'exprimer en terme
de pourcentage de terrain dans la ville
de Solidar qui serait contre les par les
Ukrainiens ou par les Russes puisque des
bâtiments des rues des angles de rue
changent demain constamment la situation
est extrêmement violente les Russes sont
dans la ville de Soledad mais ne
contrôle pas la ville on ne peut pas
dire en ce moment que les Russes
contrôlent la ville les Ukrainiens
affirment défendre mes admettent
effectivement que il est très difficile
ils disent infligés des pertes très
importantes sur les Russes c'est
absolument incroyable aussi parce qu'on
a vu des vidéos tournées par carbone
ukrainien on voit bien la tactique
employée par ces mercenaires de Wagner
qui sont envoyés parfois très légèrement
armés vers les positions ukrainiennes
dans la ville et aux alentours de la
ville de soleda mais je pense qu'il est
clair que les Ukrainiens subissent et
très importantes aussi voilà tous ces
appels réitérer aussi par keV à recevoir
un soutien logistique on sait que volodi
mirzuelinski attendait des armes
supplémentaires à la France a déjà fait
des des promesses on parle beaucoup
aussi des fameux léopards allemands qui
qui sont sur le point d'arriver
entretenu hier à le vivre dans l'ouest
de l'Ukraine avec son homologue polonais
que la Pologne enverrait je pense une
quinzaine de cet ongles par mais
seulement dans le cadre d'une coalition
internationale il faut que la Pologne
obtienne Laval de l'Allemagne pour
envoyer ces temps allemand l'Allemagne
de la voie du chancelet olafchal se dit
ne pas avoir reçu de demande pour le
moment mais l'impression qu'on a c'est
que la Pologne est d'autres pays aussi
veulent mettre la pression sur des pays
un peu plus réticents comme l'Allemagne
de fournir justement ces temps que à
l'Ukraine c'est un peu la France qui a
selon Paulo dinosaelenski en tout cas
ouvert la voie on annonçant c'était
juste à la fin de l'année dernière je
pense l'envoi de ces véhicules de
reconnaissance qui peuvent être
classifiés comme des tanks techniquement
c'est des tanks mais c'est des temps que
léger pas des temps que d'assaut pas des
chars d'assaut l'Ukraine réclame de car
comme c'est léopard par exemple merci